hi um this is an amazing moment to see
all of you here it's been a long time
coming uh for this Vision to come true
um I'm going to start with just a
personal story I am a child of war and
revolution I was born in Iran and I lost
my nation to the Islamic regime uh in
1979 um last year we we saw our young
women protesting bravely for their
freedom um and I had to do something and
I reached out to Elon who's a dear
friend because I was the founder of
hyperloop um and I was able to get
starlinks smuggled into Iran to the
women to be able to communicate with the
world without the government being able
to block
it it's one small step for me to do
something like that but it's a signal of
what we all notice right now in our
world the nation state as it exists um
for citizenry who are the consumers of
the nation state is not relevant anymore
um many of our our nation states are
being run by gangs they're being run by
dictators they're being run by corrupt
politicians it's time for something new
it's time for the network
State um in 2012 just a little history I
had lunch with uh Joe ondale and
proposed this idea of building private
new city states um and BAGI and I became
dear friends and I've watched him give
birth to this movement and I just want
to say and maybe we all say a great
thank you to BAGI for starting this
movement
so my day job is as a entrepreneur and
venture capitalist I started a venture
studio and fund called Edison Alpha and
I've been working for years on basically
proving that this idea of network states
can work in the physical world uh at
Uber uh I was an early board member and
investor and what we called it was we're
do we're basically doing atoms and bits
it's the physical and the digital
combined together in
synchronicity and what this is is is the
idea of let's build a completely new new
city um and I spent many years uh
working on two different projects I'm
going to talk about one of them in
detail today um and I call this concept
smart
Islands so there's an island called
Norman's key uh in the Bahamas it used
to be owned by Pablo Escobar speaking of
gangsters um and the good thing that
Pablo did is he built an air airport to
the right uh for his drug running
operation um and this is how he got all
the cocaine into America um it's a it's
quite a one of the most beautiful
islands that I've ever seen um and NASA
has actually studied all the Waters of
the world via satellite and this is the
clearest water in the world you don't
have to go all the way to uh to the
Pacific Ocean to see it um you you can
see it right here this is only a
40-minute flight from Miami and the
thesis is that we can build U basically
the Hamptons of of uh Miami and and Palm
Springs um and we've actually built it
um my friend of mine and a business
partner uh Nadim Ash actually bought
this island in the financial crisis uh
in 2009 and committed to build it and
when I met him he hadn't started it and
I had my birthday party there invited a
lot of my friends everyone fell in love
with it and I said you know what I'm
going to invest I'm going to buy in
let's go so we got Joseph dur one of the
famous French architect and designer to
design the entire all of the buildings
and the homes um it it is absolutely
stunning and I invite all of you to come
visit as soon as we're done um and we
just got Norman Foster the famous
architect to come to the island and he's
fallen in love with the island and he's
designed the 150 person restaurant um
we've built a marina uh bigger than uh
bigger than um uh St Barts uh you can
actually bring you know Yachts of any
size boats of any size here all of that
infrastructure is going into place and
this is the airport the airport can
actually land uh G650 is and it's
something as an insight for our smart
islands is each of these Island projects
needs to have its own airport and
Customs so we actually got that done
with the bamian government there is um
our own customs and airport and people
can land here from anywhere in the world
they don't have to land somewhere else
and then have you know you know hours of
of uh Logistics to get
there just in in closing I want to
basically uh mention that one of our
next projects is an island that is
bigger than Manhattan uh we're in the
middle of negotiating the the uh the
treaty essentially but it'll be a
99-year lease with the nation uh to
basically create the equivalent of our
first network uh State uh that you can
all move to so thank you so
much